the Iowa caucuses turn into a total
cluster bleep every Democratic leaders
victory and president Trump prepares for
the State of the Union I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show the Ben
Shapiro show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your online privacy today from
like the Democrats in Iowa and
expressvpn dot-com /ban again this
expressvpn calm / Ben so let us begin
with the best Iowa caucuses ever these
were amazing so the party that wants to
handle your health care it wants to run
the economy then wants to run every
aspect of your life and they promise you
government is supremely confident and
they are supremely confident they can
handle everything okay don't you worry
don't you worry there won't be any death
panels there won't be any rationing of
care they can make sure that all the
payments hit the providers exactly when
they are supposed to everything will be
hunky-dory they couldn't handle an Iowa
caucus last night now I will be honest
with you yes because that's what we do
here on the show yesterday I was in a
really bad mood leading up to the Iowa
caucuses the reason I was in a really
bad mood is because the horse race of
Democrats is really off-putting to me
because I think frankly that most of
these Democrats are awful I think
they're awful I think there are a couple
that are sort of palatable and then I
think most of them are just garbage so
Joe Biden is somewhat palatable in the
sense that he's a corpse and he's not
gonna do too much damage to the country
if he's president not the sort of damage
that you'd see from some of the radicals
in his own party mainly because again
he's not an alive person and then
there's Amy Klobuchar and Amy Klobuchar
wouldn't do tremendous damage to the
country in the same way that some of the
more radical members of her own party
would but the big winners last night
were expected to be the people who
exactly would do that kind of damage so
Bernie Sanders who's basically a
communist I mean he says he has not
changed his views since 1963 well in
1963 dude was a communist so I'm pretty
certain that he's still comfy
considering that he has never actually
backtracked on any of his old views from
the 1960s in the 1970s I pointed this
out on Twitter yesterday the entire left
went insane I pointed out that thanks to
Andrew Kaczynski at CNN he uncovered a
quote from Bernie Sanders in 1976 when
he was 35 years old looking for contrast
I am 36 ok so Bernie Sanders is my age
and he was talking about nationalizing
every major industry in the United
States including banking and the energy
sector all of it ok and I
to doubt that Bernie Sanders had never
been asked a serious question about this
that one person had asked him about at
one time and his campaign events and
well Bernie's been incredibly consistent
and then Chris Cuomo asked him about it
and then he said well I didn't blend you
have not as may a Burlington Vermont and
the answer is right because as mayor of
Burlington Vermont what we're gonna do
municipal eyes a national institution
like your honor of the powers of mayor
of a city to nationalize anything also
you have to explain on an ideological
level why you were for nationalization
then but you are not for nationalization
ok fine so Bernie was widely perceived
to be the frontrunner going into Iowa
and then there was Elizabeth Warren but
a great ground game in Iowa she been
fading but Elizabeth Warren is a damned
liar who spends her entire life lying
about her old positions and then lying
about her new positions the kind of
person who goes out on the campaign
trail and explains why her next
Secretary of Education will have to be
approved by a random trans child
literally a thing that she said
literally a thing that she said that she
wants to regulate misinformation online
and prosecute people for distributing
misinformation online from the lady who
claimed that she was a Native American
for three decades and then he had
peabody judge who pretended initially to
be a moderate and then came out as a non
moderate and suggested that everybody
who voted for Donald Trump was actually
a brutal vicious racist and suggested
that everybody who is a Christian who
didn't agree with beep Buddha judges
take on same-sex marriage was somehow a
bad Christian which sort of flies in the
face of you know the entire old and new
Testament so in any case this was a bevy
of not wonderful people who are going to
win the Iowa caucuses last night it and
and one of them was gonna end up with a
big boost in momentum now the way that
the Iowa caucuses work is that there'd
be a boost in momentum only if you can
make a big speech that night
so the best-case example of this is
Barack Obama in 2008 wins the Iowa
caucuses John Edwards comes in second
Hillary Clinton comes in third and
Barack Obama gets up and he makes a very
famous speech this is the speech where
he says that this is the moment when all
the seeds began to recede this is the
moment when it began to take back the
world and all this kind of garbage Ryan
you got this big bump moving into New
Hampshire
I believe Hillary Clinton ends up
winning New Hampshire in 2008 but Obama
ends up with the momentum and hands of
going on to win the nomination in order
to seize that momentum you have to have
a clear result in Iowa or at least clear
enough that you get the media boost in
the aftermath of Iowa as a
counterexample in 2012 Rick Santorum
actually wins Iowa right he beats Mitt
Romney in Iowa but the early results
tabulated show that Romney
I'm sure that Romney and Santorum are
basically neck-and-neck and it's a few
days until we find out that it was Rick
Santorum who actually won by which point
it's over right Rick Santorum doesn't
get to make his big I won Iowa speech
and so he doesn't get that big boost
going into New Hampshire which was gonna
be a Romney State anyway okay so last
night going in there are a few stories
one is Democrats are gonna have heavy
turnouts gonna be massive turnout people
are so excited to throw this bastard
Trump out of office they want him gone
and they're gonna show up in huge
numbers huge huge youth wave everybody's
gonna show up second it's gonna be a
competent well-run well-executed caucus
three weeks in advance the Democrats
were talking about how well-run how well
executed this thing was going to be how
we have tested this thing we are ready
for it and we know it's a little
complicated because we're gonna report
three separate steps here we're gonna
report first the rah-rah vote total
which they didn't do last time
now's the stop to Bernie Sanders because
last time Bernie Sanders did well on the
raw vote total and he didn't do quite as
well in the actual caucus totals he
ended up losing very narrowly to Hillary
Clinton in Iowa in 2016 so they're gonna
report the raw vote totals and then
they're gonna report the caucus totals
and the caucus totals were a second
round of voting okay so that was all a
stop to burning so this was the plan the
plan was that Bernie was gonna at least
win the raw vote totals and then if he
didn't win the caucus then he could talk
about how his jobs and then the media
would make a big deal out of it and
burning would be the man with the
momentum coming out of Iowa well none of
that happened none of it because it
turns out that apparently apparently the
Russians hacked
Iowa it's amazing I mean I don't know
how this happened and no one knows how
it happened but it's incredible I don't
know if Joe Biden was in the back room
unplugging the app like the weird guy
from airplane I have no idea how any of
this happened I don't know if by
shifting Kansas City into Kansas as
opposed to Missouri president from
screwed up magnetic fields in Iowa which
borders Missouri in the north I I don't
know what happened here but no one knows
what happened there are no results none
zero zip zilch we have no idea there's
not been a single tabulated vote in Iowa
maybe later today we got some results
the Sanders camp has been releasing its
own results of this thing we don't know
if those results are legitimate and
Biden's been like you can't release
results preliminary none of that has
been actually verified so now you're
screwing with the process you're
screwing with the election integrity and
Bernie Sanders's people are like no this
is all a cheat right now
Twitter CIA mayor our CIA Pete is
trending and so his mayor cheat so the
Bernie Sanders people are like Buddha
judge screwed this whole thing up if it
wasn't for Buddha judge then we would
have walked away with this thing but
somehow he cheated and so they're all
it's a circular firing squad of
incompetence in idiocy and these people
want to run your health care this is
their plan he's highly competent
technocratic national nationalization
friendly Democrats once run everything
in the world but they cannot run a
simple process where a bunch of people
get together in a gym and decide which
candidate they like best we're gonna
bring you all the details cuz it was
spectacular across the board it's so
good and listen is it good for democracy
oh no I mean no it's never good for
democracy when somebody screws up the
process this badly but the Democrats had
it coming and frankly it really screws
with the democratic process Nate Silver
has analysis of that too so we have a
lot to get to with regard to these Iowa
caucuses because this is one of the
great screw-ups in American modern
American electoral history it's that in
just at one second first listen we all
get the future wrong we do we all get
like if you are Democrats who excuse me
okay we're gonna have a smoothly run
Iowa caucus but you know you should have
done you should purchased insurance for
your caucuses and if you don't know
what's coming in your life you should be
purchasing life insurance you should be
insuring yourself against the
possibility of future loss more
importantly insuring your family against
the possibility of future loss how do
you do this you go over to policy genius
they make finding the right life
insurance a breeze and minutes you can
compare quotes from the top insurers and
you can find your best price you could
save fifteen hundred bucks or more a
year by using policy genius to compare
life insurance policies once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home and auto insurance
disability insurance get life insurance
right now be a responsible human being
make sure your family is taken care of
go over to policy genius com we will
always get the future wrong it's better
to get life insurance written again get
all the rest of your insurance there too
home insurance auto insurance disability
insurance and get a bundle like get all
the good stuff over a policy genius.com
make sure that you're insured against
the future in a way that the Iowa
Democratic Party simply was not policy
genius.com already so what exactly went
down Politico has a great run down this
morning the title is it's a total
meltdown confusion grips Iowa with Noah
official results in sight good good
according to Natasha kuraki Alex
Thompson and David ciders reporting a
technical meltdown in Iowa
Monday night set off bedlam in the
critical first contest for the
Democratic presidential nomination
triggering competing claims of victory
and stoking doubts about the legitimacy
of the eventual outcome no results had
been reported by midnight Eastern by the
way it is not midnight Eastern anymore
okay we are now like more than 12 hours
removed from this and that we still
don't have results no results have been
reported by midnight Eastern and the
Iowa Democratic Party said on Tuesday
morning it plans to release caucus
results as soon as possible today while
also emphasizing its ultimate goal is to
ensure the integrity and accuracy of the
process meanwhile candidates stepped
into the Boyd every Democrat
simultaneously rushed to the microphone
to claim victory I mean it looked like
it really looked like a clown car it was
like a clown car they opened the doors
and every Democrat rushed to the mic
they were on split screens like
Elizabeth Warren was on a split screen
with Joe Biden both of them claiming
some sort of victory but as political
points out the biggest winner might have
been sho Biden because according to the
Iowa entrance poll he was hovering close
to the viability threshold a 15%
statewide but he was doing really poorly
I mean according to most of the exit
polls according to most of the reports
from precincts Biden was not performing
at all like Biden there's a good shot
that Biden was gonna come in either
either fourth or fifth that he might
have even finished behind Amy Klobuchar
which had been disastrous finish for Joe
Biden who didn't bother to build an
organization on the ground in Iowa which
is unthinkable because the only thing
that matters in Iowa is your
organization SP Buddha judge shows dude
has seven percent nationally but he's
there was a good chat who's gonna win
the Iowa caucuses last night he's the
one who's hardest hit I mean you're just
looking at who's hardest hit big winners
big losers last night Buddha judges the
hardest hit because Buddha judge is the
one who needed the biggest bounce right
Sanders has a national organization
he has scans of money he's likely to win
New Hampshire Buddha judge really needed
the balance Buddha judge not gonna get
the bounce because there are no results
coming out of Iowa he had spends all of
his time and all of his money and all of
his organizational ground game in Iowa
he's got to be very disappointed today
to have that victory stolen from him so
while the burning people are bitching
about this the person who really got
jacked last night is people who to judge
okay Bernie Sanders was gonna be a big
win or two and then he was gonna claim
he had this wave going into New
Hampshire that gets swamped it gets
stopped Iowa basically gets taken off
the table as a state
manners right there's some delegates
allocated but no big news no big
headline for Bernie Sanders Elizabeth
Warren has a bad night because there was
a good shot that Elizabeth Warren ends
up certainly in the top three maybe in
the top two in votes and maybe in the
top two in delegates once all of that is
said and she needed that she really
needed that bump going into New
Hampshire because Warren does have to
win New Hampshire in order to have a
future beyond New Hampshire right in
order for her to to do well in these
caucuses and in these primaries she
actually does have to be seen as the
alternative to Bernie Sanders that only
happens if she over performs in New
Hampshire she needed that bump in New
Hampshire she's not gonna get that bump
not from Iowa anyway so those are your
big three losers which are all of my
favorite candidates right all the people
who I can't stand the most in the
Democratic caucuses really got jacked
last night they got jacked hard and this
is why they're all claiming that the
party establishment that this the party
establishment didn't do this the party
establishment is scared bleep 'less of
Bernie and his crowd they're scared
bleep list of Elizabeth Warren and her
crowd the last thing they want is to be
seen as the conspiratorial elites
cramming down an alternative to Bernie
again cuz this happened in 2016 then a
lot of burning voters stayed home that's
the last thing that they want the people
who are helped the most
well Amy Klobuchar art was denied a
headline but her headline telling me
that break she's gonna finish like forth
so she gets sort of the perception that
she was doing well or that she was doing
okay and so she ends up in in fairly
decent position framing Club which are
who really has no national hopes at this
point Joe Biden is the one who has saved
Joe Biden again the man was expected to
completely collapse early last night and
the early results were showing that he
was in a state of complete and utter
disarray that he was win it like the
Bernie Sanders team has released these
unverified results they're unverified
results show Bernie up at like 28% and I
believe it was it was boo to judgment
like 24 or 21% and weren't like 18 and
then it was Joe Biden all the way down
there like 12
I mean Colby chart like 11 so he's just
a disastrous night for Joe Biden except
the night never happened it's like the
night just disappeared from memory as I
Brigadoon in the Iowa caucuses they
appear every four years and then they
fade back into the mists of time and so
this whole thing falls apart so that's
sort of how this thing pays off for the
various candidates it is especially good
for Joe Biden according to Nate Silver
because if you were trying to build a
forecast of how the future primaries go
the weight
to Iowa makes a big difference so
according to Nate silver he says more
specifically we estimate based on
testing how much the results in various
states have historically changed the
candidates position in national polls
that Iowa was the second most important
date on the calendar this year trailing
only Super Tuesday it was worth at the
equivalent of almost 800 delegates
almost twenty times its actual numbers
thanks to that magnitude of the balance
that comes out of Iowa and Nate silver
says everything was a little weird in
Iowa this year there were already some
signs that the Iowa balance which
essentially results from all the
favorable media coverage the winning
candidates get might be smaller than
normal Iowa's bracketed by an extremely
busy news calendar president from some
Pietschmann traveled before and after
the caucuses the Super Bowl on Sunday
the State of the Union address on
Tuesday there was not the usual
climactic uptick and media coverage
around Iowa and the worst news for the
Democrats and all of this is that the
turnout in Iowa ended up being pretty
low okay which is a really really bad
indicator for the Democrats like a
seriously bad indicator for the
Democrats originally the Democrats had
suggested that this was going to be the
highest turnout ever in Iowa because
people were so excited to get rid of
Trump nope nope the Democrats are now
acknowledging that it was on pace for
about 170 to 170 mm people showing up in
Iowa which by the way demonstrates how
ridiculous this whole system is 170 2000
people deciding for the rest of the
country sort of who is going to be the
front-runner in Iowa is pretty
astonishing the record high was 240,000
in 2008 that's when everybody was very
enthused about Obama and about Hillary
and now it's like 170,000 which means
the enthusiasm is really not as high as
the Democrats suggested but says Nate
Silver we weren't prepared for what
actually happened which is that as I'm
writing this at 3:15 a.m. on Tuesday the
Iowa Democratic Party literally hasn't
released any results from its caucuses
I'm not gonna predict what those numbers
will be although early indications are
that Bernie Sanders people to judge and
perhaps Elizabeth Warren had good
results and the point is that the lead
story around the 2020 Iowa Democratic
caucuses is now and will forever be a
colossal bleep show around the failure
to release results in a timely fashion
maybe there will be eventually a
decent-sized iowa balance despite all
this but there's a good chance all the
candidates who did well in iowa gets
screwed and the candidates who get who
did poorly there get a mulligan so who
might this help
so according
to nate silver he says the presence of
Iowa on the map was helpful to Bernie
his chances of winning at the National
delegate majority would have been 24
percent without Iowa as opposed to the
31 percent chance he had with Iowa as of
Monday afternoon
if Bernie had walked to walked out with
Iowa if he had walked out with a big
lead in Iowa then his chances of winning
a majority of delegates would have shot
from 31 percent to 58 percent who had
been the prohibited frontrunner if
Bernie had won Iowa but there is no
winner in Iowa why Iowa doesn't exist
Iowa's just in your mind Iowa's a
figment of your imagination and so that
means that right now without iowa
existing the chances of Biden winning a
majority of Delegates
are now 50 percent according to Nate's
over with but with Sanders lagging at
24% because this means that the biggest
headline that coming out now will be New
Hampshire everyone expected burning to
win New Hampshire he won it last time
and that means that Biden gets a reset
so right now if Biden is not expending
bajillions of dollars caucusing in
Nevada he's big right he's got a
second shot if he's got a second bite at
the Apple because last night he was
gonna get walloped he was gonna get
Wallops I mean we'll get to the Joe
Biden problem in just one second and
we'll see how the media covered this
thing throughout the night it was it was
amazing how this thing morphed
throughout the night we'll get to that
in just one second but first let's talk
about the fact that we are now
approaching a Valentine's Day now I know
you hadn't thought about Valentine's Day
until I just said it right cuz a couple
weeks distant but this is why you should
be listening right now so you don't wait
until the last moment then rush over to
a gas station and pick up some flowers
or some bad sushi for your wife on
Valentine's Day it makes you look like a
doof instead what you need to do is go
to the best place on the interwebs to
get jewelry for your wife I'm talking
about the pearl source at the pearl
source you get the highest quality pearl
jewelry and up to 70% off retail prices
I know because I've gotten jewelry from
the pearl source before I know the
people who run them they're unbelievably
trustworthy I'm good friends with folks
who run the pearl source really like
I've known their family for a very long
time it's a family-run business it's
fantastic and their jewelry is super
high quality I got my wife earrings I
got my with a pearl necklace like these
are beautiful beautiful things that
we're gonna be able to hand down to our
daughters as well at the pearl source
they cut out the middleman by
eliminating markups traditionally five
times the original price and selling
directly to you instead you can even
customize your jewelry based on pearl
size quality gold type length and many
more choice
if you need it quickly for Valentine's
Day that's no problem because the Pearl
source offers free two-day shipping on
every single order everything comes
beautifully packaged in an elegant
jewelry box ready to be presented as
soon as it arrives and if you're not
sure that she's gonna love the gift if
you're afraid of your own taste
well the Pearl source comes with a no
hassle 60-day money-back guarantee so
it's risk-free I promise you're gonna
love the jewelry
it is excellent as I say these are
trustworthy folks and it's a great great
value if you want find pearl jewelry at
the best prices online go straight to
the source the Pearl source that is the
pearl source comm slash Ben and enter
promo code Bennett check out again
that's the Pearl source calm slash Ben
and enter promo code Ben at check out
great prices great jewelry they're great
people really I trust them go check them
out the Pearl source comm slash men
enter promo code Bennett check and I
promised your wife mom
girlfriend sister everybody's gonna love
this stuff from the pearl source go
check it out right now
okay so first let us begin with the
recap of the night so early on in the
night before the extent of these scrubs
became clear and it is it is a nightmare
for the Democrats because as it also
turns out the app that failed last night
was originally designed allegedly and
Robby Mook is denying it but Robby Mook
who is a Hillary Clinton staffer
allegedly designed the app that just
failed so if you want conspiracy
theories we shall bring you conspiracy
theories and because that is J I mean
what a disaster he's saying I didn't
have anything to do with it except there
were public reports that he was involved
in the initiator in the initial stages
of developing the app that was used in
Iowa by the way Democrats who are
constantly complaining about Republicans
want to crack down on voter fraud and
use voter ID and don't want online
voting yeah how did online voting go for
you last night though real good was that
was that real solid pick for you how's
all this working out your new fancy tech
is it working out great
it isn't oh sorry to hear that in any
case the early story in the night before
any of this started was that Biden was
collapsing right Biden gets saved last
night because the big story last night
was Biden collapsing so Jake Tapper was
on the ground in Iowa and he was walking
up to Biden supporters and there were
like two of them and they were saying
that don't worry were viable we'll get
up to they will get up to the fifteen
percent threshold and tappers like when
next year because there's like two of
you Biden how we doing over here this
does not look like 56 people so the
Biden granted Biden group
so you're you're you you look like
lovely wonderful people but it doesn't
look like you made this viability
threshold yes not there's time this year
I'm not trying to be funny but okay so
this was the story last night is that
Biden was collapsing in on himself like
a dying star Chuck Todd was immediately
saying last night the Joe Biden was done
based on these results because Joe Biden
was finishing solo I mean maybe
finishing fifth in the Iowa caucuses
here was Chuck Todd early on in the
night before Chuck Todd lost it and
declared that Iowa was it was an effing
disaster anything that he said on a hot
mic nerves checked and clearing Biden
dead Biden he's interesting he's an
afterthought in these college towns and
that is it only you know he's the
electable guy but Sanders big shot at
him is can he get young voters out it
it's not a good look if you're not even
getting threshold okay so that that was
the story right and then Chris Matthews
was on MSNBC you think I know it's going
on here Joe Biden I think he's dead now
coming out roll on in here come on a
show drink heavily mild rumpled a lot of
people in here so I got a tenant hold it
together but look at that crowd for Joe
Biden done let's jump Biden it's like a
walking dead nays corpse go Chris
Matthews go it's the first rule when
Iowa because 9 out of 11 Democratic
presidential candidates who won I will
won the hole won the nomination for the
only people that did where the local guy
Tom Harkin and a neighbor of dick
10-point so it has always been a really
good leading indicator but this time I
think we got a lot more game ahead of us
I have a lot more game ahead of us with
Bernie coming out really strong I
believe the first couple contests
staying strong for a while by now don't
know if he's gonna make it we'll see
tonight if he makes it on ok so they
were already declaring Biden dead early
on and then Katie tore at MSNBC was
reporting the other big story which was
of course turnout was incredibly low
right they were expecting big turnout
and nobody showed up because no one
likes these candidates in terms of
turnout in 2016 they had around 767
people here they were prepared for twice
that many number over a thousand they
thought at least at this precinct they
had 804
so turnout was not quite as high as they
expected here and I'm not sure if that
says what that says about maybe the
evening maybe people were busy or maybe
there were so many candidates they
needed someone else to choose for them
but keep that in mind turnout was not as
high as expected although it did exceed
expectations at least in this one
precinct or alternatively maybe the
entire Democratic theory which is that
people hate Donald Trump with such a
fiery passion outside of the major
cities that they're going to show up on
mass in order to stop Trump
maybe that's just not true maybe that's
just not sure there's a new Gallup poll
out today shows Trump all the way up to
a forty nine percent approval rating if
his approval rating is forty nine
percent the day of the election he's
gonna be able reelected and there's no
question he's gonna be reelected because
the fact is he won election with a 41
percent approval rating last time if
he's any more close to 50% this thing is
a done deal it's a done deal okay maybe
the fact is that outside of California
and New York where everybody is morally
upset about Donald Trump the rest of the
country is like okay yeah we've all
taken it in we know what Trump is and
guess what we're not willing to hand the
country over to full fledged socialists
right now so weren't enough we're not
we're not all that interested we're not
maybe maybe nobody is up for this stuff
the Beltway insiders were so into
impeachment and Muller reporting every
inch of the news cycle maybe that's not
reflected in the middle of the country
because the Democrats in Iowa who showed
up in 2008 cuz they were excited about
both Hillary they were said about
turning a new page right Hillary and
Barack Obama a new wave in the
Democratic Party maybe they look at
Bernie annoyed and then we'll combine oh
my god is dead and they look at people
who to general like this guy's mayor of
South Bend Indiana like really and then
look at Trump they're like all right
like don't like him think he's a doof
but like I'm not really like do I really
want to get up and go to a gym tonight
and like hang out with a bunch of people
and pretend like we are doing something
important for the country okay so those
were the early narratives the Biden was
done and also the turnout was low and
then the evening turned then the evening
turned in a glorious and wondrous way
everything started to fall apart
so CNN was the first to start reporting
and things were clearly off so last
night CNN reports yeah we got a problem
here on these vote tallies they are not
happening properly we'll get to this in
just one second first let me tell you
about a great Valentine's Day gift it's
almost Valentine's Day love is in the
air you know it's better to have in the
air the smell of cookies cookies
okay this should be the easiest sell in
the world honest
I shouldn't even have to do this ad for
you I'm offering you cookies for
Valentine's Day if you don't love
cookies I don't know who you are Stalin
Mao cookies are the best thing that ever
was okay and this is why you should get
yours you should get your special
someone mrs. Fields Cookies the best
kinds of cookies when debbie field
started mrs. Fields Cookies 40 years ago
she won over sweets lovers everywhere
with her gooey chocolate chip cookies
melt in your mouth brownies and passion
for sharing the joy of baked goods for
this Valentine's Day send a gift to your
partner significant other secret crush
since your wife to your mom mrs. Fields
will deliver a heart-shaped tin of
treats or heart-shaped cookies anywhere
in the country and ordering is
absolutely easy and if you're ordering
as gift you can add a personal message
and pick the perfect cookies just for
them best of all mrs. Fields offer 100%
customer satisfaction guarantee I love
mrs. Fields stuff and some of its kosher
and it is excellent
I mean top-notch so I mean how could
anybody reject this gift how could
anybody be unhappy with this gift you
get mrs. Fields Cookies for Valentine's
Day that's a person who loves you to
sweeten the deal our listeners get 20%
off your entire order when you go to
mrs. Fields calm / Shapiro that is 20%
off any gift and mrs. Fields calm / a
pair of 20% off your entire order mrs.
Fields calm / superior cookies are on
the way and honestly if somebody gets
cookies and they don't like them they're
a bad person check them out mrs. Fields
calm / capiro for 20% off any gift okay
so CNN begins reporting fairly early in
the night that something is clearly off
we've got a problem the app isn't
working people reporting they were
typing things into the app in the Apple
is immediately freezing people reporting
data was sort of disappearing people had
not fully tabulated results properly
many of the campaigns were complaining
that there were problems with the
initial tabulations and with the
secondary tabulations people didn't
understand how the process works if
they're reporting things wrong because
it's all complex' and stupid okay so
here is CNN reporting we got a problem
guys
this was not the plan they like
something is clearly off from the plan
that the Iowa Democratic Party had at
the start of the night they did not
expect to have no vote reporting at
10:30 Eastern at night that is
dramatically later than we've seen in
the past so mark is right it's a brand
new process in the sense of what they're
reporting out there not just the state
delegates but also the popular vote for
the first round and
so I understand that they are doing
something brand-new
I get Bernie's people were bitching
about this you did this okay you're the
ones who insisted that the Democratic
Party report the initial vote
assessments before the caucus tallies
that was you so you know eat it
I don't think that the Bernie people
have that right to be angry really I
think Buddha judge has a right to be
angry like Bernie's gonna do fine he's
even gone to New Hampshire but he's
gonna be competitive throughout Bernie's
gonna claim victory and you know he did
win a lot of votes last night by pretty
much every indicator Buddha judge was
the one who is gonna miss that giant
boost that he was gonna get the signal
boost that he was gonna get after
winning Iowa who's gonna be able to give
his Obama speech by the way we'll get to
the Democratic speeches in just a second
because it was delicious but this caused
no end no end of heartburn for Democrats
the best clip of the night best clip of
the night so Wolf Blitzer was
interviewing a precinct captain okay
somebody actually who's interviewing
somebody at the NCO headquarters
okay oh sorry cuz I'm wrong he's
interviewing a precinct captain on CNN
that person was on hold with the DNC
headquarters in Iowa getting ready to
report results wolf is on the line with
the precinct captain and the DNC guy
picks up the phone and the precinct
captain who's been waiting an hour to
report the results is busy with wolf and
he says hold on a second wolf by the
time he picks up the phone with the Iowa
chair the guy hangs up on him so because
of CNN a precinct captain is unable to
report the results of a caucus it's
unbelievably great here is the clip of
the night from CNN this is a real
coincidence wolf I just got off hold
Jessica so I've got to get off the phone
to report the results all right now go
ahead and report news what can we listen
in as your report them so on yep okay
hello yes the Democrats who could not
wait for 10 seconds on the line the guy
waited an hour to report the results in
the Democrats like hello hello
click yes yes and Wolf is like can we
listen in as you report the results
absolutely you can wolf
excellent excellent stuff so Chris
Matthews has a solution why are you
starting Iowa
can't do this anymore I didn't get home
and drink it's late
I'm even here what that's going on where
is Iowa anyway isn't it like the place
where Kevin Costner plays baseball go
chris matthews go I think the reason
they keep saying if they go too much to
a primary here and it begins to look
like every vote counts simply go in you
vote you leave then they're afraid they
won't get first anymore because then
there'd be the first primary and New
Hampshire's the first primaries how
would they have the right today I don't
know Michael knows a lot about this from
the Republican side we got to get Tom
Perez in here and beat him up a little
bit make them tell us why do you still
start in Iowa because it's a strange
decision it just is sorry it's cold I'm
here it's cold I know why the hell I'm
here he says I mean I here for like
three years a hot toddy to get me
through the evening coming here with my
hairbrush to the shoe then even bother
to put together a show list or any sort
of real show just come here and talk
that's how you run a caucus I'm not in
charge of the Democratic Party got Tom
Perez in here I wanna kick the crap out
of him I'm gonna beat him up like Robert
De Niro like rabid you know in the
irishman she's gonna kick him out of a
straight corner
shake him move all that well just like
Robert De Niro and the Irishman surely
gonna have to CGI my face it'll be a
brutal scene a brutal scene as I kick
the crap out of Tom Perez don't feel the
tingle up my leg anymore do you Tom do
you spectacular stuff and then this was
also great clip and it's being under ADA
kazoos on fox Donna Brazile who was
innately and inherently involved in
trying to skew the primary system last
time for Hillary Clinton right she was
working with CNN and she leads the
questions from CNN to Hillary Clinton
allegedly to ring the debates right down
in Brazil was on Fox News going oh this
is so terrible because now people are
gonna think that the primary system was
rigged you guys have been rigging it
it's your fault your fault you're the
former head of the DNC
oh no they might think that it's rigged
oh no yeah well maybe it turns out that
when now the democratic snake has eaten
its own tail we have no rover us on our
hands a snake eating its own tail that's
what that means
okay the Democrats have been claiming
that if Donald Trump was not impeached
there would be widespread election
problems and loss of trust in
institutions and boy were they right
Donald Trump wasn't impeach
and we do have widespread election
problems and lack of trust in our
elections here's Donna Brazile who is
complicit in helping
Hilary Clinton win the nomination last
time talking about undermining trust in
our fundamental institutions I was here
in 2012 covering the Republicans and
that night we all left here thinking
Mitt Romney was the one and we learned
later he talked about momentum matter it
matters that we get this right you know
I spent a lot of time in those rules and
bylaws committee setting up this
procedure which I've done now for more
than five cycles you want to get it
because if we don't get it accurate
somebody's going to complain tomorrow
that they were rigged something happen
okay this all led to the greatest clown
show I've ever seen on TV I mean it was
just a clown show it was phenomenal it
was great we need the Benny Hill music
or something right then I don't I can't
we need yakety sax because it's so good
so the Democrats suddenly realize in the
middle of the night they realize wait
there's not gonna be a winner tonight
and Amy Klobuchar is like so no matter
what happens I'm not gonna get to make a
big victory speech and Amy Klobuchar
takes a bite or just cracks one of her
staffers over the head and runs up
onstage and she's like I won guys I'm
here i won
it was me I know we don't have results
but I did great let me tell ya it was
awesome it was it guys and if you don't
believe me I will make you eat the salad
with the comb so Amy Klobuchar out of
the sand and the senator from Minnesota
she gets up and she gives a victory
speech with no results say here was Amy
Klobuchar declaring victory and all her
fans are like yay whoo this is at 10:00
p.m. Central time last night when it
became clear there would be no results
we know there's delays but we know one
thing we are punching above our weight
my heart is full tonight so even in a
crowded field of candidates even during
the well-earned impeachment hearing of
Donald J Trump which kept me bolted to
my Senate desk for the last two weeks we
kept fighting and you kept fighting for
me okay I love this I love that she's
giving a victory speech with no results
it's spectacular it's spectacular
my favorite thing about this is by the
way if you're Amy Klobuchar and like
your only shot at the nomination is to
do well in Iowa don't you have a better
scripted speech than that like why don't
you have a barn burner set up just give
a barn burner she was smart to get out
there in front of the cameras first
though and this led to a jailbreak of
democratic candidates a criminal justice
reform in the middle of the Democratic
primary and all of the all of the
Democrats rushed from jail directly to
the cameras so much so that it turned
into an episode of Hollywood Squares
like it was like Joe Biden here and it
was with Warren here and Amy Klobuchar
here and P Budaj edge here and somewhere
Tom Steyer was speaking to a counter but
nobody cared it was amazing like they
were all rushing to the cameras it was
spectacular I'll show you the rest of
this because believe it or not Joe Biden
and Elizabeth Warren ended up on a split
screen and many of the networks we're
covering Biden but not Warren which led
Warren be like everybody's a sexist and
also they hate Native Americans oh wait
I'm not Native American we'll get some
more of this in just one second because
all of this if you're not enjoying this
folks if you're not enjoying this and
let me recommend that you that you check
your sense of humor because this is
inherently hilarious it is okay so it's
inherently it is a comedy of errors it
is a near Shakespearean level comedy of
errors
it is much ado about socialism it's
fantastic we'll get some more of this in
just one second first let me recommend
speaking of comedies bears have you ever
had one of those situations where a car
breaks down and you know kind of what
part you need you go to the auto parts
store they don't have the right part
because it's kind of a specialized part
or you go to the auto parts store they
give you a generic part and it doesn't
end up working all that well or you go
there and it turns out that you don't
know what to do with that generic part
because you're not an auto expert and
it's not directly made for your car you
overpay you wait in line all of that
well instead of do it that's happened to
me it has it's happened to me at least
once maybe twice this is why you should
go check out Rock Auto calm Rock auto
calm is a family business serving Auto
Parts customers online for 20 years
head on over to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they've got everything
from engine control modules and brake
parts to tail lamps motor oil even new
carpet whether it's for your classic car
your daily driver get everything you
need and a few easy clicks delivered
directly to your door
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts they've got amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need Rock Auto comm check
out rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about a spot so they know that we say it
helps them it helps us as well Rock auto
comm help out our advertisers rights
appear on their how did you hear about
us box if you're looking for auto parts
Rock Auto calm all right we got to get
we're gonna get some more of this the
Hollywood Squares elements of the Iowa
caucuses in just one second plus the
impeachment is coming to an end and
Trump is speaking tonight State of the
Union address the Mosman ARCIC stupid
institution in American life I'll get to
that in just one second first if you
haven't noticed 2020 is wild man it is
wild and the election race is just
getting started we know that you need to
know everything from debate and primary
updates to the latest nonsense from the
Democratic candidates and the best way
to stay informed join daily wire get
comprehensive news and opinion from us
on demand so we are giving you 20% off
all new memberships yep that is 20% off
all new memberships when you use promo
code DW 2020 members get our articles
have free access to all of our live
broadcast and show library the full
three hours of the ben shapiro show
select the bonus content access to the
mailbag and now our new all access to
your gets you into live online Q&A
discussions like the one we are hosting
tonight after backstage state of the
union will be streaming at 8:30 p.m.
Eastern 5:30 p.m. Pacific to bring you
Trump's speech live with our analysis
and then we'll answer all of your
questions in an exclusive online Q&A
over at daily wire.com slash discussions
I didn't even know about that last part
I'm kind of mad about it but we'll be
there so you should be there too again
that is promo code DW 2020 for 20% off
join today stay one step ahead of the
left on all things 2020 related we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so the so amy klobuchar our runs to
the camera and this sets off a chain
reaction where every democrat decides to
run to the camera simultaneously
it's like kiddush at my shul like
everybody's running to grab the herring
like boom brawls full-on brawls it's
like it's like Black Friday at the
Walmart everybody is just piling on top
of each other trying to get to the
cameras like it's a zombie apocalypse
and we're all try and get to that last
axe it's Finn freaking tastic so Bernie
then leads to the microphone he says
when the results come in
we'll have done very well this of course
is true Bernie did get Jack not as much
as booty judge but he got Jack last
night here was Bernie talking about how
when the results come in we Belov what
the problem is he didn't get the big
moment he didn't get the big moment
right he wanted the big moment and he
needed the big moments who catapults him
not just a victory in New Hampshire but
two broad victory in New Hampshire
instead just seems like a guy who won
New Hampshire last I was gonna win New
Hampshire this time
so here's Bernie being robbed of his
moment I imagine have a strong feeling
that at some point the results will be
announced and when those results are
announced I have a good feeling we're
gonna be doing very very well just
spectacular just spectacular
so really really great stuff Bernie's
like I don't know where I am also we
need to nationalize healthcare show we
couldn't handle a primary sure
everything here is a crap show but you
know it will be good is if you changes I
recommend it that have completely failed
here what if we instituted those on the
national level with regard to your
health care so if you have cancer you
can now go to a caucus in Iowa and you
can figure out whether you can convince
enough people whether you should have
chemotherapy Bernie Sanders man the fact
that this guy is your Democratic
frontrunner and that the media have not
vetted him I mean this is I'm never
gonna stop saying this the fact the
media have not vetted this communists
for three decades is beyond insane
beyond insane okay this man has been in
national politics longer than I have
been alive on planet earth and still
nobody has seen any he's now run in two
consecutive elections and been very
competitive in both and no one has seen
fit to ask him he has said his views
have not changed since the sixties and
no one has seen fantastic okay so if
you've used
didn't change since the 60s how about
that time you were defending Cuba
Venezuela and Soviet Union did your
views on that change at all I mean the
view see holes are not manifested Lee
just wrong they are manifestly evil on a
variety of topics and he will not be
asked a solid question by the Democrats
because he just keeps saying things like
Norway and Denmark it's like okay well
yeah but for decades you were defending
the Soviet Union in Cuba so what is your
point of differentiation in any case
Bernie
robbed at this moment the man whose most
rounded with his moment is people who to
judge who was buy most of the data
expected to either win or come in second
in Iowa particularly after the caucuses
now he has a controversy of his own
going on the controversy is that if you
look right behind him in the speech what
you will see is a bunch of people of
color right we found Pete Buddha judges
six black supporters and they were all
standing behind him okay I'm not making
that up
he littering to one of those humans one
of those humans literally said that Pete
Buddha judge went out and picked black
people from the crowd to put behind him
during this speech and one of the one of
the black women standing behind him said
the people who judge like took her away
from her friends and brought her behind
him said it would look like he had a lot
of black support so here is people who
to judge giving a speech that nobody saw
because it was again a clown car last
night tonight an improbable hope became
an undeniable reality by all indications
we are going on to New Hampshire
victorious
now there were skeptics an awful lot of
skeptics who said not now
not this time all this talk of belonging
and of bridging divides is too naive too
risky so tonight I say with a heart full
of gratitude Iowa you have proved those
skeptics wrong
okay well Iowa actually proved that they
don't know how to do an election so
that's that's really what they proved
last night I also love mayor Pete suing
the Hopi changee thing directly after
calling 65 million Americans racist
which he did in the last 48 hours that's
exciting stuff the best part of the
night though was when Joe Biden went to
the mic at the same time as Elizabeth
Warren and they basically started
clawing the mic from one another was
pretty spectacular so Joe Biden gives
his speech which is to say words come
out of his face but they're not quite
intelligible and also he may not be
alive here is Joe Biden being a not a
live human we're gonna get this results
get them straight and I want to make
sure they're very careful their
deliberations and indications are more
indication is going to be close we're
gonna walk out of here with our share of
Delegates we don't know exactly what it
is yet but we feel good about where we
are and look so so it's on in New
Hampshire and I'm gonna get on a plane
and get the hell out of here cuz I
really underperform I love that Amy
Klobuchar is like we punched above our
weight and booty Church like we proved
everything to the world and Bruce is
like we did amazing here and Joe Biden's
like and people voted hey every
Democrats like we did amazing here he
booted judge we proved all the haters
wrong we did we proved all the haters
wrong giving me even is the Obama
inflection even and Bernie like and when
all of this is said and done when when I
claw back against the voter
redistribution that has happened here
I'm the one percent of the voting
condition and Joe Biden's like we'll
leave with our share of Delegates I
don't know the share is how many people
that is but by the rules we have to
leave with our share of delegates
because otherwise that's illegal and
also by and then just hops on a plane
it's like go to New Jersey see you later
and this is the last anyone will ever
hear of any of these candidates in Iowa
again
because that is from territory and
Trump's gonna win Iowa running away in
hey but as Joe Biden was speaking
Elizabeth Warren she sent up some smoke
signals and then she and then she exited
her teepee and she went up and she
discussed how she was just getting
started which is to say that she is not
just getting started she's in serious
trouble because she needed the bump more
than any of these other candidates in
New Hampshire cuz New Hampshire borders
Massachusetts she should be competitive
for first place in she's not competitive
for first place at Bernie is running
away with it in New Hampshire here is
Elizabeth Warren trying to claw back
some attention again she jumped up there
at the same time his Biden so they put
them on a split screen it was Hollywood
Squares
it was the Brady Bunch they're putting
Marcia in the corner I mean it was just
amazing here is here's Elizabeth Warren
together together we have built a
movement powered by hopeful courageous
people who will do the work to make the
change we need know and we're just
getting started this race will be
decided by people like you well and then
she just sort of went away so said sad
day for Elizabeth Warren who presumably
will have to go back to hunting Buffalo
as per her declaration of her Native
American heritage so well well done
Elizabeth Warren complete utter crap
show for the Democrats now the biggest
problem or the Democrats of course is
not for any of these candidates because
in the end the candidates gonna be who
the candidates gonna be Bernie Sanders
still has the leg up Bernie is gonna be
widely perceived to him on Iowa he's
gonna win New Hampshire and then we move
on to Nevada Joe Biden if he proves to
be as lackluster in New Hampshire as he
has proved to be in Iowa he's in serious
trouble Mike Bloomberg somewhere is
sitting in his billionaire lair and he
is just sipping a glass of Chianti and
he is and he is Michael Bloomberg is it
maybe he's just like a nefarious
billionaire from the movies I'm
wondering if maybe Michael Bloomberg is
sitting there and he's smoking a pack of
banned and cigarettes and sipping from a
16 ounce can of coke and boiling up his
12-gauge shotgun and going everything
here is going exactly according to plan
because you know it looks best in all of
this Michael Bloomberg who didn't even
compete and I write all the rest of
these Lilliputians are running around in
Iowa pretending that any of this matters
and then the thing turns out to be a
complete cluster so who what what
actually matters here what matters
is the perception that the Democrats
don't know what the hell they're doing
and can't get their act together so if
their claim has been all along that
Donald Trump is incompetent the Donald
Trump runs a chaotic bleep show the best
way to prove to Americans that Donald
Trump should stay in office is to prove
that you run your own chaotic bleep show
he can't even run in Iowa caucus and yet
you want to run our health care you want
to run our energy sector you want to run
our economy you want to run Wall Street
you know best you have a plan
really you didn't you have a plan to get
like 170,000 people's votes tabulated
seriously we have more people listen to
that to this show in like a five minute
increment then listen then voted in Iowa
last night and they could not handle
that they couldn't handle it so well
done everybody on the Democratic side if
you want to prove that you're
incompetent in the run-up to 2020 you're
doing a hell of a job and it's not just
they're doing a hell of a job on that
they showed that they were completely
incompetent when it came to impeachment
because impeachment is now sputtering
toward a verdict this is the New York
Times word sputtering toward a verdict
because the Senate was not for they will
not get a single Republican vote now
let's face it
okay the Democrats keep saying things
like well you know the Clinton
impeachment there was bipartisanship
nope there were five Democrats in the
House who voted in favor of Clinton's
impeachment and none in the Senate who
voted for his removal so this one is
about as partisan as the last one which
is to say Democrats voted one way
Republicans voted another the
Republicans are gonna vote to acquit
president Trump probably tomorrow is the
lid this is gonna go the Democrats push
that off past the State of the Union so
that there would be the awkward
spectacle of Trump giving the State of
the Union in front of a house that had
impeached him and Senate Democrats who
wanted to impeach him but honestly
Trump's just gonna say from is not gonna
say anything about it if he does say
something about it it will be and now
I'm about to be acquitted because this
is all bull crap and then they move on
the Democrats really botched this you
can tell because a Nancy Pelosi is
shrieking to the sky that they did not
watch this and when Nancy Pelosi has to
keep insisting that she did not in fact
botch this that she's not own she's not
owned she screams as she slowly shrinks
into a corn cob Nancy Pelosi says she
always knew impeachment would end this
way with the acquittal of President
Trump is according to the New York Times
well except that she claimed that she
was gonna be able to get bipartisan
support and that you should never have a
wholly partisan impeachment and then she
did exactly that
Democrats argue that miss Pelosi won by
losing setting the stage for an election
that is not only about kitchen table
issues that carried them to the majority
in 2018 but also about exposing the
president
as unfit for office and Republicans as
complicit in his misbehavior in an
interview Monday Pelosi said Democrats
had forced Republicans to do what mr.
Trump never has admit he was wrong to
pressure Ukraine to investigate his
political rivals well know pretty much a
large number of Republicans including or
surely said from the very outset that
the Ukraine code was not perfect but
this was also not impeachable the
Democrats accomplished nothing you know
what the best proof is that the
Democrats accomplished nothing that
trumps approval rating is now at
all-time highs according to Gallup he
has now hit his personal bests of forty
nine percent that poll was taken during
the Senate trial he was up ten points in
the Gallup poll since the Ukraine craze
in October so Democrats have proved
themselves incompetent in Iowa they've
proved themselves incompetence in
impeachment it's complete complete
disaster for the Democrats it turns out
that not there's a huge backlash to
Democrats but they have shown the world
that they are not competent to handle
anything and they showed it right at the
outset which of these Democrats looks
confident is Bernie does Bernie look
like a super competent guy is it
Elizabeth Warren who's run a complete
meltdown of a campaign is it Joe Biden
who doesn't look like he's alive is it
Nancy Pelosi you just botched an
impeachment hearing by rushing the thing
for without any witnesses and then
whining that the Senate wouldn't call
the witnesses that she herself had
failed to call like where exactly is the
level of democratic competence so the
Democrats had a couple of attacks on
Trump right one was that he was volatile
the problem is the American public are
used to the volatility at this point I
think most Americans knew he was
volatile and he was elected most
Americans are no longer shocked by the
volatility we get it
that's who Trump is and then the
Democrats had a secondary line which was
Trump is deeply immoral and we are
deeply immoral and I'm sorry nobody buys
that we all know that that's partisan
hackery you're the party of Bill and
Hillary Clinton nope button worked in
work in 2016 and can work in 2020 and
then there was the final line of attack
which is Trump is incompetent and here
they at least could point to the cast
inside the administration and the fact
that the administration is kind of a
mess internally they could point to all
of that except they just demonstrated
that they do not know how to punch their
way out of a paper bag they demonstrated
that they do not know how to play a
simple game of chutes and ladders it's
incredible I mean truly amazing so well
done Democrats you have in the first
week of the actual election demonstrated
your full-scale incapacity to do basic
things
you claim that you want to run all of
our healthcare good luck for that
president from tonight
state of the union so I may remind you
that tonight we have the backstage live
at 8:30 p.m. Eastern 5:30 p.m. Pacific
you should subscribe over at daily wire
and use DW 2020 to get 20% off and then
you can ask us questions during the
backstage live ok time for a quick thing
I like and then we will get you a quick
thing that I hate so things that I like
today there is a magnificent article in
The Guardian that is just wonderful by
poppy nor it is titled why liberal white
women pay a lot of money to learn over
dinner how their racist now the short
answer is because the morons the long
answer is because they want to
demonstrate how woke they are by paying
a bunch of people of color to tell them
that they are bad right this is their
paying for their own malice struggle
sessions now according to the Guardian
freshly made pasta is drying on the
wooden banisters lining the hall of a
beautiful home in Denver Colorado
foxhunting photos decorate the walls in
a room full of books a fire is burning
in downstairs a group of liberal white
women have gathered around a long wooden
table to admit how racist they are
recently I've been driving around seeing
a black person and having an assumption
they are up to no good says Alison
goopster immediately after that I'm like
that's no good that is human just doing
their ding why do I think that this is
race to dinner
a white woman volunteers to host a
dinner in her home for seven other white
women often strangers perhaps
acquaintances each turn across 2500
bucks which can be covered by a generous
host or divided among guests a frank
discussion is led by co-founders Regina
Jackson who's black and Sarah rau who
identifies as Indian American they
started race to dinner to challenge
liberal white women to accept their
racism however on however subconscious
if you did this in a conference from
they leave rouse says but wealthy white
women have been taught never to leave
the dinner table Rao and Jackson believe
white liberal women are the most
receptive audience because they're open
to changing their behavior they don't
bother with 53% of white women who voted
for Trump white men they feel are
similarly lost cause okay well if
they're already voting the way you want
them to vote then I'm happy that you're
guilting them I'm happy or making them
feel bad about themselves I mean that's
exciting stuff and there is something
wildly delicious about watching a bunch
of socialists pay each other to call
each other names that's pretty fun white
women are uniquely placed to challenge
racism because of their proximity to
power and wealth says Jackson if they
don't hold these positions themselves
the white men in power are often their
family friends and partners it seems
unlikely anyone would voluntarily go to
a dinner party in which they'd be asked
one by one
what was a racist thing you did recently
by two women of color before appetizers
are served but Jackson and Rao have
hardly been able to take a break since
they started these dinners in the spring
of 2019 so far 15 dinners have been held
in big cities across the United States
okay so let's just calculate that it
cost 2500 bucks for dinner let's assume
that 500 bucks goes toward the food
because there's only like 7 people there
so let's assume that 500 bucks goes
toward the food so let's say that that
Jackson and Rao are clearing 2 grand at
dinner here's a 2 grand a dinner they've
cleared a 30 grand - let's have liberal
white women genuflect before the altar
of intersectionality that's pretty good
business that's a pretty solid business
really capitalism always wins gang
pretty exciting stuff the women who
signed up for these dinners are not most
who would who most would see as racist
they're well-read and well-meaning
they're mostly Democrats some have
adopted black children many have
partners who are people of color
some have been doing work toward
inclusivity and diversity for decades
but they acknowledge they also have
unchecked biases
aha so what they're doing is preying on
women who really are not racist and then
they have to prove they're not racist by
claiming that they're racist right this
is the way that this works the
counterintuitive way that the
intersectional mind works is that if
you're not a racist and you say you're
not a racist
you're a racist if you are not a racist
and you say you are a racist then we
know you are not a racist because you
acknowledge your own racism even though
you're not a racist so that means you're
not racist so if you say you're a racist
or not a racist if you say you're not a
racist you're a racist
you got it that's how all of this works
and you can make 2,000 bucks for the
privilege pretty suck I mean this is one
of the great khans I have ever heard of
seriously I don't know how to get in on
this thing but this is like I will
invest in in Jackson and around just as
a capitalist proposition I will give
them free ads on this program for this
thing if they will cut me in on the back
end because I have a feeling there are a
lot of morons out there who are eager to
pony up to be absolved of their racism
by Jackson and Rob because now what do
they get to tell their Lilly once that's
really enough they get to tell all their
liberal friends yes you know I didn't
know I didn't acknowledge my own biases
until I went to this until I went to
this dinner a Tom wolf the famous writer
they wrote a fantastic fantastic essay
that was back in the 1960s I believe
it's printed in the electric acid
kool-aid test and the entire essay is
about how this is basically what
liberals been doing since the 60s
there's a dinner at Leonard Bernstein's
house right Leonard Bernstein incredibly
wild leftist there's a dinner at his
apartment and the Black Panther
right who at that time were actually
like a criminal group and people quit
engaged in criminal activity like racial
criminal activity showed up at Leonard
Bernstein's apartment and these black
panthers would tell liberal white women
about how they wanted to kill whitey and
how whitey was the problem in all this
and the liberal white women would swoon
because now they get to go and tell all
their friends how they got up close and
personal with people who've been
victimized by the American system and
they know their own complicity they
would say as they reached into their
Chanel handbags for for their there for
their cigarettes I mean the whole thing
it was ridiculous read the essays it's
one of the great essays in American
literary history by Tom Wolfe all about
again the the way that the liberal white
world in New York and Manhattan pander
to this so this is just the extension of
that circa 2020 Campbell Swanson was one
of the hosts just camp will Swanson she
says she comes across as an overly keen
college student applying for a
prestigious internship she can go for
days about her work as a political
consultant when it comes to talking
about racism she chokes I want to hire
people of color not because I want to be
a white Savior I've explored my need for
validation I'm working through that yeah
I'm struggling she stutters before
finally giving up that is wonderful
listen to that quote it's so good she
wants to hire black people but she can't
say that she wants to hire black people
to give black people an opportunity
because if she says that then she's the
white Savior and black people don't need
a white Savior so she has to give
another reason why she wants to hire
black people that is not contingent on
them being black but if she makes it non
contingent upon them being black she's
colorblind which means she's a racist
like if you think of the decision tree
here to not be a racist at the end of
every decision is your racist right so
if you say I'm hiring a black person
because I wanna help black people too
bad you're racist or white Savior if you
say I want to hire this black person
because they're the best qualified
you're colorblind you're racist if you
go out if you say I want to hire a black
woman because I am a racist then they're
like okay and then everybody else is
like well but if you're a racist why do
you wanna hire a black woman I don't
know because I'm a racist I want to hire
a black woman but then you're using the
black person to absolve yourself of sin
so no no good right so no matter what
the end of every logical proposition in
this insane mindset is you're racist and
you get to pay money for the privilege
across from Campbell's fronds and Morgan
Richards admits she recently did nothing
when someone patronizingly commended her
for adopting her to black
children as though she had save them
what I went through to be a mother I
don't care if they were black she said
opening window for round a challenger so
you admitted his stooping low to adopt a
black child and Richards accepts that
the undertone of her statement is racist
ah all the Wonder the wonder so a woman
adopts two black children which adapting
to children of any color is a good thing
adopting two black children as a white
woman sometimes means something
depending on where the black children
came from right I mean if you're talking
about a white woman
adopting white children then you are
accused of racism because you have to
adopt somebody of the same race but if
you're adopting cross racially then
sometimes there are additional
sacrifices that are associated with that
for the black child and for the white
parent because now you have to face down
the reality that there is racism in
society and you're gonna have to face
that down to way you wouldn't have had
to if you adopted a white kid right I
mean this is just a reality I have many
friends with dotted black kids Nick
seriously adopt it has a black son David
French has black daughter right and
there are additional challenges
associated with that if you point out
that it's a good thing to cross racially
adopt you are secretly a racist even
though you gave these black kids who are
maybe not even be adopted maybe they
were orphans maybe they were in an
orphanage maybe they're in foster care
this woman adopted black kids therefore
she's bad because you pointed out that
she was adopting black kids even though
again it is a reality that you're going
to experience additional challenges I
mean I thought the premise of the left
is that racism is prevalent in American
society if that's the if that's the if
that's the premise then it also happens
to be true presumably that if you adopt
black children then you're going to face
additional challenges in society you
wouldn't if you adopted a white kid and
that has nothing to do with you being a
racist that's it that's a recognition of
reality but apparently if you recognize
that reality you're also a racist as
more confessions like this are revealed
rau and Jackson seem to press those they
think can take it while emphasizing with
those who can't well done for
recognizing that Jackson says to soothe
one woman we're all part of the problem
we have to get comfortable with that to
become part of the solution
amazing amazing stuff it's just it's
it's spectacular so well done and
Guardian welds on liberal white women
I'm so glad that you have decided that
you are going to shell out thousands of
dollars for the privilege of being
called a racist well done okay quick
thing I hate and this is gonna take long
obviously the news broke yesterday that
rush limbaugh revealed that he had
advanced late stage lung cancer or
advanced lung cancer that is horrific
rush is a totemic institution in
American politics he has been my entire
life rush mentioned this yesterday on
air here's what Rush said so I have to
tell you something today but I wish I
didn't have to tell you and it's it's a
struggle for me because I I had to
inform my staff earlier today I can't
escape even though telling people are
telling me it's it's not the way to look
at it I can't help but feel that I'm
letting everybody down with this but the
upshot is that I have been diagnosed
with advanced lung cancer diagnosis
confirmed by two medical institutions
back on January 20th first realized
something was wrong on my birthday
weekend January 12th and I wish I didn't
have to tell you this and I thought
about not telling anybody I thought
about trying to do this without anybody
knowing because I don't like making
things about me obviously our prayers
are with rush rush is the godfather of
talk radio which means that really he's
the Godfather of podcasting as well rush
is somebody I grew up listening to every
conservative I knew grew up listening to
Rush Limbaugh he is going to be seen no
matter what happens as a historic figure
in history the Republic really a heavy
force behind the contract with America
during Newt Gingrich's time really a
force during the Bush administration a
force against the the radicalism of
Barack Obama and a force in favor of
President Trump obviously Rush Limbaugh
is is a person who helped inculcate an
entire generation into basic
conservative principle I will admit
freely and proudly that I was a graduate
of his Institute of advanced
conservative Studies as were millions of
other Americans and his impact is gonna
be felt for generations all of our
thoughts and prayers with Rush and his
family his family is wonderful as well
and
and I think that we're all praying for
him today and we all should be praying
for him day was really upsetting news to
find that out yesterday
you know rush is he said he has the best
medical care and and obviously we're all
we're all behind him and despite the
fact that the left is vile and we're
tweeting vile things about him rush is a
a good person who has done amazing
things for the country
alright move back here a little bit
later today with two additional hours
and then a backstage live tonight at
8:30 p.m. Eastern 5:30 p.m. Pacific
we'll see you then
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel why
douse key technical producer austin
stevens playback and media operated by
nyx even associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam sy events audio
is mixed by mic foramina hair and makeup
is by Anika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2025
hey everybody its Andrew clave and host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]